[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast
episode 913.
that's not right it's 83 isn't it it is
83.
again still a big note how did i not see
that cuz things have been busy i didn't
notice that it was a prime number
usually i noticed that about midweek but
uh
here it uh caught me off guard but i
think we can recover yes i think so too
um this week we are going to formally
announce our book a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century
and uh do read a little excerpt from it
and talk about how we will be talking
about it
in the weeks leading up to the
publication which is in september
and then we are going to talk about as
part of that hyper novelty
about lab leak hypothesis about
show you some graphs of coded cases and
fatalities before and after ivermectin
in several countries around the world
shared with us by dr pierre corey who
you brett had on a live stream on
tuesday of this week truly
extraordinary if you haven't listened to
it we're going to talk a little bit
about why randomized control trials are
so
awesome but not the only kind of
evidence and um
monkeying with the baseline covid
edition does that sound like a nice
tight tiny like we got our work cut out
for us yeah yeah
i think so too um so just a few
announcements before we
before we launch in uh you had one of
your monthly patreon conversations this
morning you'll have another one tomorrow
uh also on the last sunday of each month
we do a private q a
at mine we encourage you to come join us
at either of our patreons where on
either of them you also get access to
the discord server where there is a
lively conversation that is often
happening there
we will not be here next week because
we have some faring to do as our boys go
off to one of them goes off to camp in
farnam in california
and uh our producer actually zach
if you want to show my screen for a
moment is going off to the finals
of the um of the american rocketry
challenge tarc uh sponsored by the
national association of rocketry so
uh seriously yay team that is awesome
um but those things are both happening
next saturday so we're gonna try to fit
in another live stream sometime between
now
and two weeks from now but we won't be
here for our regularly scheduled live
stream
next saturday uh one thing that will be
happening for sure
um between now and then is that i'm
gonna be joining trigonometry along with
jordan peterson
for a live show uh next friday at juneau
on june 11th at 12 30 pacific
where that'll have a live q a as well so
um if anyone is interested in that you
can
join us there and
anything else announcements wise
logistics wise
well um odd note i'm not actually sure
whether monk debates had yet publicized
the fact that i was supposed to be on a
monk debate this monday
about the question of the lab leak
hypothesis and whether or not a
preponderance of the evidence pointed
to a laboratory leak my
would-be interlocutor has dropped out of
the debate
um possibly as a result of threats um
but also that was the claim also
possibly because he realizes that the
degree
to which the natural origins hypothesis
is now taking on water
was at such a rate that by monday he was
going to need at least a snorkel if not
scuba gear
so maybe he didn't have time to source
it
probably didn't maybe you know who's to
say whether he was even licensed for
such things but let's just say
for a snorkel all right
one no longer needs a license for a
snorkel thank god for that one
once did the the snorkel nanny state is
long dead
this it'll be back i have a feeling we
will be licensing snorkels the
uh the snorkel show loophole is going to
be a matter of much debate
it's uh a lot's coming so anyway yes
there uh there will be no monk debate
this monday because there's no one to
take the other side of the issue anymore
i think indicating that um we've done
well with the lab leak hypothesis we
have
certainly beat expectations and
although the world is rapidly scrambling
to write
the wrong story so that nobody could
possibly learn the actual lesson of the
lab leak hypothesis saga we'd have at
least
lodged in the public mind that this is
not an improbable scenario
it's almost like the media doesn't want
us to be able to do science or recognize
science when it comes our way
it's like they need us not to be able to
in order to keep doing what they do
right
i get it which you know maybe change the
business model a little bit such that
science can happen and progress can
happen and we can
say avoid things like what we're living
through right now in the future by
applying the scientific
method early and often totally yes
i interrupted your role though i'm sorry
about that did you i think so what kind
of a role was it
that kaiser role i would have thought
maybe a dinner roll
yeah no i think um i think we're ready
to
to talk to talkbook so zach if you would
put up
uh the website that we now have up for a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century this
is our book that we've been talking
about writing for well over a decade i
remember being in a comparative
anatomy lab with students back in like
2010
talking about our ideas for this book
and it's finally come to fruition
we're super excited about it we
encourage you to uh to look at the site
and to um consider pre-ordering we at
the moment
um there's there's people have been
asking about getting signed copies
and there's not a way for us to interact
with the publisher such that we can
actually sign copies and get them to
people
but two things we're likely to put up a
button here soon that any time
that you have pre-ordered you would be
able to go in and
enter your information and get a signed
book plate which is not the same
but we're also hoping to do some live
events in the fall
and there will also be more information
about that coming
coming soon but at live events if they
have you know we will be trying to do
some in places where there's actual
interest and if you showed up to that
there will be book signings as part of
that
we would far prefer to sign actual books
it seems the right way to us as well but
if you think about the logistical
problem of getting the books to the pen
and then to you
it becomes well that's actually that
it's it's not the books to the pen and
the books to you it's the it's the uh
it's the contractual agreement with the
with the publisher oh there's an
additional layer that i uh
yeah no the the physical stuff i i got
that
figured but it's the it's the
contractual stuff we would need another
another uh structure or something but
yeah yeah so i will say also on the
point on the uh
from the point of view of looking at the
website uh probably most of you will
encounter things on your phones because
that's what's done but you should go see
if you can't dig up
a a laptop somewhere to look at the site
from the uh the desktop because um
all of you have been begging for a
parallax scroll you will only
it's not a parallax scroll there's a
parallax scroll
you know so let's not go here that it
didn't end up being what happened
so um it sure looks like it's an
animation rather than a parallax scroll
we do not need to go inside baseball on
this but the
the guys who are working on this did an
amazing job and there were
internal technical reasons as well
better than a parallax scroll we
simulated a parallax scroll with
animation which is even cooler so
check that out on the desktop site
indeed
um so what we are going to do over the
next
13 weeks or so if you would just scroll
up a little bit zach
is each week we're going to do a segment
of the podcast devoted to
one of the chapters and so i'll just
read for those of you
listening and not looking the names of
the chapters and so started whenever our
next live stream is
um we will do a little excerpt from and
discuss the human niche
and then a brief history of the human
lineage which is the deep history
of like our life on earth ancient bodies
modern world
chapter four is medicine then food then
sleep
sex and gender parenthood and
relationship
childhood school becoming adults
culture and consciousness and the fourth
frontier
so some of those will be a little bit
opaque at this point but they will
become less opaque as we talk about them
and certainly
um if you end up reading the book
so today what we're going to do is
uh just read an excerpt from the
introduction and then talk about it a
little bit
all right so this is this is actually
the second half of the introduction the
first half has a story
um of a you know nominally near-death
experience that we had
in our very first season doing field
work um many years ago which i am not
going to read on air here it was one of
our earliest near-death experiences it
was one of our earliest near-death
experiences
so i'm going to read from the
introduction starting after that story
many people have attempted to explain
the cultural dissolution we face
but most have failed to provide a
holistic explanation that not only
examines our present
but also looks back into our past our
whole past and into the future
we are evolutionary biologists who have
done empirical work on sexual selection
in the evolution of sociality
and theoretical work on the evolution of
trade-offs senescence and morality
we are also married to each other have a
family together and have often been side
by side while exploring many parts of
the globe
well over a decade ago when we were
still college professors we began
formulating the idea for this book
we stood on the shoulders of giants our
mentors and senior colleagues as well as
many intellectual ancestors whom we
never met
but we're also building curriculum that
was unlike any that came before
we forged new paths and posited new
explanations for patterns both old and
new
we came to know our undergraduate
students well and as they engaged our
curricula they asked questions across
domains
what should i be eating why is dating so
difficult
how do we create a more just and free
society
the common threads throughout these
conversations in classrooms and labs in
jungles and around campfires
were logic evolution and science
science is a method that oscillates
between induction and deduction
we observe patterns propose explanations
and test them to see how well they
predict things we do not yet know
we thus generate models of the world
that when we do the scientific work
correctly
achieve three things they predict more
than what came before
assume less and come to fit with one
another merging into a seamless whole
ultimately in this book and with these
models we seek a single consistent
explanation of the observable universe
that has no gaps
takes nothing on faith and rigorously
describes every pattern at every scale
this goal almost certainly cannot be
attained but there is every indication
that it can be approached
though we may glimpse this endpoint from
our modern perch we are a long way from
reaching the limits of what can be known
that said we are much closer to the goal
in some areas than in others
in physics we seem tantalizingly narrow
theory of everything which really means
a complete model of the least complex
most fundamental layer of explanation
and here we've endnoted your brother
eric weinstein's work
as we move up in complexity things
become less and less predictable
near the top of the stack we reach
biology where processes inside even the
simplest living cells are nowhere near
fully understood
things only get more complex from there
as cells begin to function in
coordinated ways becoming organisms made
up of distinct tissues
the degree of mystery compounds the
unpredictability jumps again in animals
governed by sophisticated neurological
feedbacks that themselves investigate
and predict the world
and once again as animals become social
and begin to pool their understanding
and divide
their labor nowhere are we more
regularly stumped than we are in
understanding ourselves
we homo sapiens are brimming over with
profound mysteries surrounded by
paradoxes one of the very things that
make us distinct from the rest of the
biota
why do we laugh cry or dream why do we
mourn our dead
why do we make up stories about people
who never lived at all why do we sing
fall in love go to war
if it's all about reproduction why do we
take so many years to get on with it
why are we so picky about with whom we
choose to do it why are we fascinated by
the reproductive behavior of others
why do we sometimes choose to impair and
disrupt our own cognition
the list of human mysteries is endless
this book will address many of those
questions it will bypass others
our primary aim here is not to simply
answer questions but to introduce you to
a robust scientific framework for
understanding ourselves
one we have developed over decades of
study and teaching on the topic
it is not a framework you will find
elsewhere we developed it by working
from first principles as much as
possible
first principles are those assumptions
that cannot be deduced from any other
assumption
they are foundational like axioms and
math and so thinking from first
principles is a power
powerful mechanism for deducing truth
and a worthy goal
if you are interested in fact over
fiction among the many benefits of first
principles thinking is that it helps one
avoid falling prey to the naturalistic
fallacy which is the idea that what is
in nature is what ought to be
the framework that we present here is
built to free us from these sorts of
traps
it is intended to allow us humans to
make sense enough of ourselves that we
can
at a minimum protect ourselves from
self-inflicted harm
in this book we will identify the most
large scale problems of our time
not through the limiting divisive lens
of politics but through the
indiscriminate lens of our evolution
one of our hopes is that we can help you
to see through the noise of our modern
world and become a better
problem solver modern homo sapiens arose
approximately 200
000 years ago the product of 3.5 billion
years of adaptive
evolution we are in most ways a generic
species
our morphology and physiology though
staggering and marvelous when considered
in isolation
are not special when compared to those
of our nearest relatives
but we uniquely have transformed the
globe and become a threat to the planet
in which we still thoroughly depend
we might have called this book a
post-industrialist guide to the 21st
century
or an agriculturalist's guide or a
monkey's guide or a mammal's guide or a
fish's guide
every one of those represents a stage of
evolutionary history to which we have
adapted and from which we carry
evolutionary baggage
our environment of evolutionary
adaptedness or eea
to use the term of art in this book we
speak to our environments
of evolutionary adaptedness which is to
say not just the eea of the title such
as the african grasslands and woodlands
and coasts on which our ancestors were
hunter-gatherers for so long
but the many other eeas to which we are
adapted
we emerged on land as early tetrapods
became lactating fur bearing mammals
developed dexterity with our hands and
visual acuity as monkeys
grew and harvested our own food as
agriculturalists and lived cheek to jowl
with millions of anonymous others as
post-industrialists
we chose to include hunter-gatherer in
the title of the book because our recent
ancestors spent millions of years
adapting to that niche
this is the reason so many people
romanticize this particular phase of our
evolution
but there was not just one
hunter-gatherer way of life any more
than there is one mammalian way of life
or a single way to farm
and we are not adapted only to being
hunter-gatherers we also adapted long
ago to being fish
more recently to being primates and most
recently to being post-industrialists
all of these are part of our
evolutionary history
this wide-ranging view is necessary if
we are to understand the biggest problem
of our time
our species pace of change now outstrips
our ability to adapt
we are generating new problems at a new
and accelerating rate and it is making
us sick
physically psychologically socially and
environmentally
if we don't figure out how to grapple
with the problem of accelerating novelty
humanity will perish a victim of its
success
this is a book not only about how our
species is in danger
of oops sorry this is a book
not only about how our species is in
danger of destroying our world
it is also about the beauty that humans
have discovered and created and how we
can save it
an irrefutable evolutionary truth
undergirding this book is that humans
are excellent at responding to change
and adapting to the unknown
we are explorers and innovators by
design and the same impulses that have
created our troublesome modern condition
are the only hope for saving it
i'm excited i am too um i'm very excited
for this to be out in the world and for
us to be sharing
pieces of it uh as as the weeks go on is
there anything you want to add
uh to that part of the introduction that
i have just read from
yeah i mean there are a number of things
in there that are key many
will be familiar to long-time viewers
and listeners
i think the idea you know i'm
particularly fond of the idea that the
goal
is a seamless integration of models at
every level
and that that cannot be achieved and we
already know it but it probably can be
approached which is
effectively the same thing that's a
really important and subtle
distinction and if people understand
that that's what you're doing it's not
that you arrogantly think that actually
a theory of everything is actually going
to allow you to go from the particle
level to predicting the next behavior of
the person in front of you
nothing of the kind but the
compatibility of all of these things
is the objective and the fact that they
are wildly incompatible at the moment
tells us what we need to figure out
right it's the incompatibility between
things that
drives proper inquiry it is that it is
a kind of perverse obsession with the
inconsistency
that turns you into a scientist right
the need to figure out how a and b
can both simultaneously be true and they
seem incompatible
as we say later in the book paradoxes
are like an x on a treasure map
right they say dig here figure like what
what is this inconsistency about
uh in in a scientific worldview
worldview you don't say ah let's agree
to disagree let's figure out what the
source of the disagreement is
and uh and figure out you know
who's got the perspective that isn't
actually a match for what is true
even if it is best for the majority of
people
actually to agree to disagree and wait
for somebody else to figure out what
fills in the gap you don't necessarily
want a society full of people obsessed
with the inconsistencies you might not
be able to do anything include feed
yourself if that's
the uh the construction of your
civilization
but a division of labor in which some
people are obsessed by those
inconsistencies and driven to
do all of the what seems like spinning
of your wheels that is necessary in
order to finally figure out what fits in
these gaps
which is often you know you can spend
literally decades
chasing something and what you find is
some elegant little thing that takes
just a minute to describe
right so you know that is a weird kind
of
investment regime right it's like having
to drill thousands of oil wells to find
one but the one
carries the necessary fluid to fuel what
you're up to and
so anyway i'm very excited uh that what
we have been doing kind of
more or less off the cuff on darkhorse
and what we did
in the classroom at uh you know very
different between you and me but a
higher level of
uh you know preparedness lectures that
had been developed over years were
deployed
upgraded each year and all of that that
that
milieu now has a kind of third place
that it lives which is this book where
we've taken
um the toolkit and tried to get it into
a form
where it's sort of you can hand it off
right yeah and anyway so this is perhaps
the most
conscious manifestation of our efforts
to use the model that we introduce
that we we talked about in the talk we
gave at princeton virtually
about a year ago that we introduced in
the first chapter of the book and speak
to
a lot more in the 12th chapter of the
book culture versus consciousness
yeah and i mean i must say the
experience of
building it has been totally educational
to me you wrote a book before i've never
been part of
uh book writing before and you know
that process even within an individual
article where you lose
objectivity about what you've said and
so you're sort of in a race against
time to get it out before you forget
what it even looks like
um that's compounded so much in this
circumstance because you're dealing not
only with the individual topics but
you're dealing with
you know how they fit together and what
you maybe said in a draft and then
it's not there anymore but it needs to
be and so anyway
i'm shocked and i must say almost all of
the work that went into keeping track of
what we did and didn't say and making
sure that we got it all
sayable and clear and you know the
immense
job of writing the book is not what i
had no idea what it even was until
we engaged in this project and that work
was almost all you i never
could have kept track of you know a
fraction of what was necessary to get
this
into a form that uh people can read it
so well here it is proofs
soon to be an actual bound even that i
just did it fedex or something
all right um one just one more thing so
we got handed
um i i didn't actually know this because
my first book didn't have an index or
maybe it did
actually i don't know it's not in this
room but i don't remember
anything about how my first book which
is about my research and life in
madagascar when i was in graduate school
antipode
um i don't remember anything about how
the index if it exists even
was created so we just got handed a
draft index that was
created by someone at the publisher
yesterday
and just began looking through it
and i admit to have a really geeky
fondness for
for indexes and books it's sometimes the
thing if i'm
back in the days when browsing in
bookshops was a thing and i love doing
it and i hope to be
really comfortable and excited about
doing it again any day now
uh when you know everyone else is also
engaged in that sort of thing
um i i will often actually look to the
index first just to to see what kinds of
topics got pulled out right and so
um i think each week we'll just we'll
just sort of throw a dart
and um craziest index ever i i i love it
so just
just the first what is this like eight
things at the letter r
just what begins the letter r in the
index we have
of this hunter gatherer's guide to the
21st century
radial symmetry rape rapid eye movement
sleep rat enrichment experiments
ravens raw food diets and rays
raised raised as in skates and rays as
in um as in the other half of the
um it's the chondrichthyes and the
elasma banks they're shark skates and
rays
yep yeah awesome this episode of the
dark horse podcast brought to you by the
letter r
that's right that's right yeah maybe we
should have uh have our
excellent producer put together a sesame
street style uh
this this episode brought to you by uh
whatever by the letter
r and the prime number 83.
that's right that's right yeah we're
doing sesame street for adults here
um all right that's what we have
on the book for this week zach i think
it's like yeah thank you
um let us move let us
you know so one thing that should be
obvious from
the excerpt that i read from and from
the little bit of conversation we had is
that
it's it's this issue of hyper novelty in
our modern world
um that is making it so difficult for us
moderns to
um to to keep up and um
boy have we all been living a
manifestation of that for the last
18 months ish 14 months 16 months
something
and um of course those those of you
who've been with us since the beginning
have been hearing us talk about
um you know about getting outside how
this disease doesn't you know this
viruses and transplant outside from the
very beginning literally from the very
first
day that we uh live streamed back in
march of 2020
we've been talking about lovely
hypothesis almost as
long once the vaccines were up and
running we were talking cautiously about
what the difference between the vaccines
were and what it might mean
you know what the what the data that are
out there might mean
and of course in the last couple of
episodes we've been talking a lot about
ibermectin as uh as a
um really seemingly
both effective and demonstrably safe
drug that could be used for prophylaxis
and treatment so we're going to go to
ivermectin
after talking a little bit about the lab
leak hypothesis
and a piece that you uh just had
published
yesterday in unheard and zach you can
show my screen if you like or you can
show it on your screen
unheard spelled very cleverly which it
took me a long time to realize was not
the standard spelling of that term
one of the things that happens in our
household is
when brett or sometimes zach now and
occasionally toby even our 17 and 15
year olds
uh will make a pun that i find
particularly egregious
i will say to them and they always know
it's coming you know it's not spelled
the same right
right which sometimes one doesn't know
but sometimes one does know and that's
kind of the joke
yes exactly that's that's part of those
those are the ones that i find
uh the the most the most powerful and
actually you know
certain puns don't work on paper because
of the spelling issues sometimes you
need them to be spelled differently
and sometimes you need them not to be no
i think i mean i think actually this is
part of why
um sort of literary types those of us
who often prefer books to
to lectures um to seeing the thing
rather than to hearing the thing are
typically less fond of puns perhaps than
than those of you who are more
more comfortable in the audio sphere i
thought you were going to say prefer
books to husbands i'm glad that you
didn't but
well i mean the thing is i can have lots
of books
not sure how to take that but all right
um yeah all right so yeah this piece in
in unheard
which uh i'm i'm quite proud of they've
got it's their flagship piece for the
weekend
that's great uh and the title and i
should tell you
um i've gotten into a little trouble
with unheard because titles are never
almost never given by the authors of
pieces they're put in afterwards so they
can catch you by surprise
and and anyway um this one is now titled
uh why we should welcome the lab league
hypothesis which is frankly a slightly
awkward title
at my insistence that uh the hypothesis
uh be there
well i was just trying to show but my
screen is showing that you can see in
the url that it still got the original
title
there yeah um in any case
what we should really welcome is the
strong probability that this virus
emerged from the lab which i realize
is going to sound crazy to people
because that sounds like a terrible
terrible thing has happened and in fact
a terrible terrible thing has happened
either way
but yes the piece goes through the logic
of
why i believe that the emerging picture
in which nobody will debate you
uh taking the side of defending the
natural origin because that's becoming
an impossible position to sustain right
that that's actually
given that that cove it happened it's a
good thing
so let's let's walk through it okay so i
mean the piece is is terrific and well
worth reading but i think that in
you know in 30 30 seconds to you know
we'll take longer because we'll riff on
it but
like we should encapsulate the argument
because it's very important yeah so i'd
like you to read it um
and i will say in passing you mentioned
your book uh
about your time as a graduate student
and it occurred to me
too late here i didn't realize it but i
talk about my time as a graduate student
studying bats but i didn't
think to have them hotlink the book
in which uh me as a graduate student
features
as an important uh piece of the puzzle
yeah and elizabeth wright's book the
tapir's morning bath
in which she identifies you quite
accurately as a maverick scientist
yes i think she was playing on brett
maverick but in any case
uh it's a it's a really cool book talk
about a great title i mean
doesn't the title tape yours morning
bath make you want to pick up a copy and
figure out what the hell that could
possibly mean
i mean it does me i'm not sure some
people will
i mean if you don't feel that same way
if you know tape here which i do
sure most people don't tape yours no i
actually saw one last time we were in
the amazon which was quite cool
i got a terrible picture of it that's
that's the kind of pictures they like to
have taken of them tend to get taken but
anyway so
the my time as a graduate student
studying bats
shows up in this piece because of the
following
phenomenon when the when heather and i
emerged from
the amazon in remind me of the date
january 2020 late january 2020
we emerged to a story our phones
leapt to life after us being out of
contact
and because we were in ecuador our
phones actually awoke to ecuadoran news
and there was a news story in ecuador
about the first
case of what was then still called novel
coronavirus
in uh in ecuador and we just became
aware of what this was and we didn't
know if this was going to be like
sars or like mers or like you know the
threats of bird flu
uh h1n1 or whatever that had passed or
whether this was going to be some major
story that we needed to worry uh even
more about
and um i did have as the
basics of the story emerged as it became
clear
that whatever this virus was
ultimately traced its origin back to
horseshoe bats
it kind of stopped me in my tracks
because as a biologist
working on bats i handled so many of
them
so many times and in fact i handled them
without any protective gear
um and the reason i handled them with no
protective gear was that that was the
standard
amongst the biologists who taught me to
work with bats and
the reason that we didn't do things like
wear gloves
was that these bats are incredibly
fragile
and they get caught in the mist nets and
in order to get them out of the mist
nets
you need all of the dexterity and
sensation in your in your fingers
otherwise you risk injuring the animals
and so anyway we learned to be very
careful with them and
good and um you know it's not like we
were constantly getting bit we were very
careful not to be
bit but there were you know vampire bats
in nets
sometimes and vampire bats have very
very uh sharp teeth
easily capable of slicing you open but
in any case we worked without protective
gear and i thought oh my goodness
we've got a pandemic that is endangering
the world
and it's come from somebody's contact
with a bat in one way or another or
something like that and i thought was i
risking causing something like this by
working with bats and not not realizing
that every contact we have with such a
creature is a
an opportunity for a pandemic to start
and it took me months to understand
why actually that was very unlikely
and the reason that it was unlikely has
a lot to do with
the evolutionary job that a
new pathogen that enters humans is faced
with
um when it jumps a uh
when it jumps a gap it has to get into a
cell
it has to successfully reproduce and
in order not to be just in a single cell
it has to spread from one cell to the
next
and then it has to jump from one person
to the next and it has to do it at a
rate that actually creates spread
right if it's too aggressive it can burn
out very quickly
if it's too timid then people recover
too quickly
and so it has to nail these things and
typically the way that happens
in those cases when it does happen is
that there's an evolutionary period in
which a
virus that is very poor at doing this
job initially
gets better at it by leaping from one
person to another
and it basically gains evolutionary
experience it adapts
so the point is if i were to have
contracted a virus
in my field work uh it would very likely
not
have been capable of these things the
chances of it making it into a pandemic
are tiny
which then raises the question about
whether or not
our assumption about the hazard of
pandemics
is too great and that elevated sense of
danger is what
caused us to do gain of function
research which yes we have not proven
that that's
where this virus came from but we were
at least creating the hazard that
something would leak from the lab in
wuhan or in north carolina or there's
one in texas
that something would emerge and create a
global pandemic that was a hell of a lot
of danger to put us to and the question
is
maybe we overrated the hazard that we
were trying to control
um all right so
take a breath is there more to say
before i say why i think we
i think we just want to proceed we just
want the sum the conclusion so that
people can encapsulate it and know
you know know what the what the it's not
a hypothesis here but know what the
thesis
the thesis is so the thesis is if you
compare the two
scenarios one scenario this has emerged
from
nature right if it is emerged from
nature then
it's going to happen again and the only
thing we can do is study these things
maybe
enhance these pathogens in order to
study them so that we can figure out
what to do next but if we enhance them
that means we're going to have natural
pandemics we're going to have
man-made pandemics when these things
leak from the lab and we're just stuck
with this forever
on the other hand if this leaked from a
lab and the danger of it leaping from
nature is lower than we think then we
can stop
taking these things into the lab and
enhancing them and thereby
eliminate the majority of the danger so
i have gone from initially saying
i really really hope this wasn't a
laboratory leak because in some sense i
don't want science to have been
responsible for this
it was the international scientific
community and i don't want that to have
been the case
but at this point that community has
behaved so badly
and much more importantly our well-being
as a species going forward
more or less depends on the fact that
there's something we can do about this
so we don't end up
with the next covet right so if this
turns out to have been
a leak from a lab what that will reveal
is that the rot at the center of the
social system that
does science both in the us and
worldwide
is is corrupt and um
has has a rot at its at its core likely
and that's terrible and i don't want
that to be true
um however the analysis that you arrive
at is
we have seen whether or not this is a
lab leak we have seen evidence of so
much of the corruption throughout so
much of this pandemic
that we're already most most of the way
to the evidence needed for that
conclusion regardless not the lab leak
hypothesis but the conclusion that
the social system that does science is
corrupted and needs to be fixed uh
then if you take the the two main
hypotheses and there are others of
course the two main hypotheses on
um on their merits without thinking
about the social implications
if this is a a zoonotic and natural
zoonotic spillover event
that suggests that perhaps something
about our changing way of interacting
with the world
changing population density is any
number of things
will will mean that this is just the
first of many
and can the world in fact deal with
another
a pandemic like this two more eight more
ten more probably not
as opposed to if this was a a virus
that was modified in a lab and leaked
from a lab
we have control over whether or not
future pandemics like this
happen yes at least potentially and i
would say there are really two
there are two things here one is the
social system that allowed this to
happen which
to my mind is actually the much more
frightening thing because right which is
why i'm still
i'm like i'm still i i still really wish
really wish uh that we that
what we now is now know is true wasn't
true
but given that it's true we've seen it
right right
um nonetheless we've encountered this
failure so many different places covet
is you know
the clearest i've ever seen it um
because and
believe me lab leak is the shallow end
right this only gets worse and
ivermectin begins to tell you just how
deep the rabbit hole goes but
um the social system surrounding uh
sense making
reporting and then whatever this thing
is that is telling us what we are
allowed to say
and think and yes it doesn't tell you in
absolute terms you can't say or think
these things but the pressure
not to admit what you privately believe
is so great and so dangerous to us that
yes that
thing and all of the things it's
connected to the the
social media platforms the regulatory
apparatus the scientific and academic
apparatus
all of that has some sort of rot within
it that is putting us in danger
well in point of correction it is in
fact telling some people quite directly
no you may not say that
by by shutting down for instance social
media accounts right what it is
or by uh reversing the decision on
papers that have been peer reviewed and
accepted and then saying ah actually not
by by keeping data and analysis
away from uh the public eye away from
scientific analysis and then also by
keeping
most of you know the the rest of us who
aren't actively doing research in this
area
um from you know keeping many people
um from actually saying what they think
uh
the conversation is beyond being steered
well okay this is my my error
some people have been told what they can
say and or think
others are not the differential nature
of this thing is bewildering because if
you look out and you say
you know you can't mention ivermectin
really i see it mentioned all over the
place in fact we've mentioned it many
many times how is it that we can mention
it and others can't right on the other
hand
if you go looking for the control
mechanism it's unbelievable right this
thing is actually resulting in accounts
being suspended etc so well and you know
our
our clips channel um got its first first
ding and uh you know this week uh for
talking about ivermectin well
our clips channel got the first it's
technically not a strike it's
technically a warning but you get three
warning or strike per channel and then
they take it
out um so this is this is google
firing a shot across the bow on our
livelihood right they have picked a
video
right they have claimed that we violated
these guidelines in some way they're not
specific so we can't challenge it
there's no venue you can file an appeal
who knows what happens there but it's
very obvious i mean it happened
you know in conjunction with this uh you
know and i did the podcast with pierre
cory live
because i wanted it to get out right um
so then we get this uh warning right
which is
uh an indication that google has
targeted our livelihood and
would like us to know that it has and
you know what it is that they would like
us not to be talking about
and you know okay this is a control
mechanism it's not absolute
right i don't expect anybody to show up
with weapons but
the fact is livelihood is livelihood and
they're threatening it so
um that whole social layer which is
somehow connected to academia and
journalism and all of the rest that
academic layer
is one of the failures and the other
failure has to do with gain of function
research and how we got here
and the gain of function research
problem
is tractable but
the problem is in order for us to learn
the right lesson
and to fix the gain of function research
problem
we have to understand what happened and
what happened involves that other layer
right so one of the things i'm watching
which is actually
causing my blood to boil is the process
of the construction of the replacement
narrative the one that does admit that
this could well have
come from the lab in wuhan right so
they're going to
admit that at some level now they're
still playing games and saying
most scientists believe this is unlikely
but we all want it
investigated as we all did all along
which is of course total [ __ ]
but the other thing they're doing is
they are steering the conversation away
from the people who saw it most clearly
early right so some of those people are
us
the one that is most galling though is
the way
yuri dagan is being shoved out of the
position
of having systematically gone through
and i would ask you if you haven't read
yuri degen's medium piece go back to it
right
here is a guy who like us was not
looking for this to be a lab league
in fact was looking for it not to be and
wanted the evidence so that he would be
in a good position to repel the claim
that this had come from the lab
and what he found out was the more you
dig the more it looks like it probably
did come from the lab
so that's an honest broker this is
somebody who's got the chops to sort it
out
he's done a very good job he and rosanna
segreto have
unearthed a tremendous amount of data
that the world wouldn't know about
without them
and so the idea that they're going to
rewrite the narrative right
you and i and the other people who were
early here
right the josh rogans the
the matt ridleys they're going to be
shoved to the side
nicolas wade is going to be the
explanation for why the world suddenly
realized that it was
making a mistake everybody's going to
claim they wanted origins and
investigated from the beginning
everybody's going to claim they never
ruled out
this possibility the stigma campaign
that was targeted directly at us was
is going to be uh you know erased from
history
and the whole point of this operation
the whole point of generating the new
narrative
is to make sure their point our point
their point
what they are doing is they are creating
the mechanism
that frees them from learning the lesson
of what what went wrong here
what they don't want to do is empower
the people who got it right and
result in the people who got it wrong
the elite
they don't want them to be ignored in
the future because they got this one
wrong right
they want everything to stay the same
and so they're going to slightly alter
the narrative so it contains more truth
yes this might have come from the wuhan
lab
but then everything else is going to be
rigged around not learning the lesson
and a system that does not learn the
lesson
right is a dangerous system it's exactly
what happened at evergreen
right evergreen bent over backwards
not to learn the lesson of the week of
riots right and it is still not learning
that lesson and it is on the brink of
failure
and this actually i'm reminded of um
[Music]
one of them one of the things that we've
done consistently as parents
and which we also talk about uh in the
relevant chapter in our book
is uh when you know when mistakes were
made a
we we seek accountability be it in us or
our children
um but dwelling on the past is only
useful so long as you can learn
from it in order to not make the mistake
again in the future
so the sort of the tagline that you
started using on our boys and that i do
too now is
it's about the future like this
yes there needs to be accountability but
this is all about the future
we won't change the past no matter how
much we come to realize that perhaps we
made errors there
what we need to do is create a better
future
than we could have if we put our heads
in the sand
and denied that we did what we did yeah
and actually you know we have a few
little tools here that work
really well to get you into the right
mindset you know it's about the future
right that's why you should be grateful
that this may have come from a lab
because we can fix that problem
exactly you can plug a leak yeah right
so
it's about the future that wasn't your
best work
right and what'd you learn you know
those three will get you a long way
yep right yeah and it turns out that not
your best work
as opposed to stamping gold stars on
people's foreheads for
any kind of effort at all is um
a much better way to create resilient
strong and yes anti-fragile children
that become anti-fragile adults
than telling them no matter what they've
done even if it is demonstrably crap is
actually really really good
yeah and you will find actually that if
you start using um
these devices that it is much easier
also to critique yourself
right like well that wasn't my best work
you know i actually i had one of these
this week so i was lucky enough to get
out um
um stand up paddle boarding on the
willamette twice this week and
um usually i just make it easy on myself
and i carry the board i carry the board
down to the water and back up separately
from like the paddle and life jack and
all the other gear um
but coming out it i go in like near
dawn-ish to avoid
basically to avoid the fast boats
because um although they make it
challenging and useful it's
more interesting you see more wildlife
if they aren't churning the water around
you
but by the time i came out there were a
lot of people where i had to come out
and
i thought you know i just want to get
everything up to the car and rearrange
there rather than leave a bunch of my
stuff down here
and so i sort of like hitched hitched
the stuff to the board
and was carrying it up these stairs and
it's like bouncing on the stairs oh my
god i'm doing a crap job here this is
really not my best work at all and i
could laugh about it i could fix it
but um you know really overall i'd just
be like nope that that was not
good decision making i didn't nothing
about that was my best work yeah not
not your best work and you know what you
learned you know yeah two trips
yeah two trips yeah so you know apropos
nothing except
not my best work not your best work yeah
yeah um
are we done with that you want to talk
about um ivermectin yeah i would just uh
say
there's a lot more in that uh article i
think there's a lot kind of buried in a
lot of threads for future discussion
uh and you know it's worth reading it's
worth it no it's excellent and check out
elizabeth's book on uh
the um long ago chapter of of my life
where i was a bat biologist
yeah tapir's morning bath the tapir's
morning bath
yeah all right so um
many of you will have seen uh brett's
livestream with dr pierre corey
one of the the founders of the flccc
frontline critical care covered critical
frontline covert 19 critical care
alliance i think we did it yeah
so flccc um and you know we'll we'll put
a link again to that site up as as we
did
for the live stream but one of the
things he left us with uh were some
powerpoint slides of data that that you
didn't show and i
i just simplified them i took some stuff
out of all the slides and i'm not going
to show everything that you left us with
and i made them
i made them simpler without changing
their their meaning at all um so
uh we're just gonna go through some of
the evidence and you can show my screen
now zach from
uh it's mexico four states in india
panama slovakia and czech republic
um and after this we're going to talk a
little bit about you know what
constitutes evidence
but for right now this is of course
there was no
explicit experiment there was
a response at the state level in all of
these cases
to to climbing death rates and then
there was a moment at which ivermectin
was introduced in different ways in
these different places and and dr corey
talks about some of those
uh in your conversation with him from
this week and we also talked about some
of them
uh on our uh livestream from a couple of
weeks ago i think 81.
um but here we go and i'm just gonna
just describe what we're seeing for
those of you who are listening although
in this case for those of you who are
listening not watching i encourage you
to come look at the slides and i'll
we'll figure out a way to put these
these modified simple slides up as a
link as well
so here we have mexico covered 19
fatalities and hospitalizations
in which the national test and treat
program began on december 29th
which is going to be right about right
well basically where you see
the gray um you had
deaths climbing um over last spring
and then declining um in the summer and
then climbing even higher
last fall and very shortly after
ivermectin was introduced in the test
and treat program
you have both deaths falling and
hospitalizations falling
okay and these data go through uh
looks like the beginning of april okay
uh next we have um in mexico this is
just excess mortality rates where
uh actually excess excess deaths
were continuing to climb as they would
of course for a while
after the introduction of the test and
treat protocol at the very end of
december
up to 280 percent of what normal deaths
would be
and as of the beginning of april
again after the introduction of the
ivermectin test and treat program
uh excess deaths were down to six
percent of
uh that's six percent more deaths than
expected on on
normal um and i'm not going to go into
it but there's some additional relevant
analysis that'll also post
on the video description from reno at
all in which they look specifically at
mexico city
and what some of the data look like
there but they're it's all consistent
okay then we have in india you know
everyone was hearing a lot about
india until i don't know a month ago
three weeks ago and we were being told
that it was a total disaster
and the data certainly do look like that
here we have and i'm going to show all
four of these
states individually at close up but for
for right now at the sort of the
aggregate view we have
goa here again fatalities in red
and excuse me deaths no
fatalities in red and cases in blue
with the gray demarcating when
ivermectin was introduced
so very similar to what we saw in mexico
similar thing in uttar pradesh the
indian city of uttar pradesh over here
similar thing in delhi and then what the
hell is going on in tamil nadu
and uh what we don't see there is any
kind of decline so
just to show you guys these a little bit
more close up here we have goa
looks very similar to to what is
happening in mexico
where fatalities and cases continue to
climb um for a short period after the
introduction of ivermectin
but then they begin to decline
precipitously and one thing that is true
that we heard dr corey saying that we've
also seen in the literature that we
found
is that um as with all
medications but certainly and clearly
for ivermectin
the earlier you get it into the patient
the better
and so it is much less likely to do any
good
um the you know the sicker they are the
longer they've been hospitalized if
they're on a ventilator and that's not
to say that it shouldn't be tried but
that it shouldn't
it should also not be surprising that uh
if you introduce ivermectin to a
population
uh many of whom are already very sick
that those people who are already very
sick do not have the same kind of
turnaround
as those people who had just gotten it
or maybe hadn't even been exposed yet
yeah i think it's all antivirals are
like this there's a huge effect of how
early
you get to it yeah um so
anyway there's there's a lot we have
several more here we've got okay
um so this is uttar pradesh same very
same
uh very similar curves in which
uh the fatalities continue to climb for
a bit after ivermectin
is introduced but then start to fall and
um
and the cases uh similarly this is delhi
very similar curves
and then what's going on in tamil nadu
um
is you know you don't see any gray box
here
basically the and i think i've somehow
erased i didn't end up
um yeah i um ah here we go in the state
of tamil nadu the chief minister
prohibited the use of ivermectin
ordering ram dassavir instead and you do
talk about this in your conversation
with dr corey remdessevier
at a average price per dose of three
thousand dollars
compared to ivermectin an average price
per dose of three to twelve dollars
we're talking about two to three orders
of magnitude less expensive
not under patent and oh by the way also
ivermectin is effective and rem deciber
does not appear to be
so in the state of tamil nadu case rates
and fatalities are still going up and
there has not been
widespread use of ivermectin
in panama we see something similar
both kate this is just this is the same
kind of uh data but they're
both on the same graph where both cases
and fatalities
um had an early surge back in the summer
declined again back in the fall of 2020
climbed precipitously through
last fall late fall into the winter
and then when panama officially
recognized ivermectin as a copper 19
treatment you see both cases and
fatalities falling dramatically
in slovakia something similar
and finally in the czech republic
the czech republic is interesting
because there were two earlier surges
both of which were recovered from so
it's it's a little bit less clear but
really all of these curves look very
very similar and there's not a one
there's not a one that when ivermectin
gets introduced
the cases continue to surge the
fatalities continue to surge
that is a pattern that we do not see
and i should point out you need to think
about what it means to introduce
ivermectin in these states it's not like
somebody
snaps their fingers and suddenly
everybody has ivermectin at their
disposal it's like that's the moment at
which it begins to enter the population
and um scott adams tweeted yesterday
over the
delhi numbers he said i want somebody to
check this this looks fake
right the numbers are so precipitous and
it was like
28 000 uh
28 000 cases i believe it was
on april 20th at the peak
um april 22nd iver mekten
is introduced and 480 cases is the
number
as of yesterday right so it's like this
amazing
crash that is so dramatic it's it's
unmissable now
of course skeptics and we should all be
skeptics we'll say look
these are waves they go up and down
right but but here's the delhi
numbers that we got from the flccc and
dr corey not my graphs um i just simply
all i did was simplify their graphics a
little bit i didn't change any of the
numbers or the actual graphs
that's that that is what they are seeing
as well those are the numbers that
they're getting and the source here is
from
api.cova19india.org so i've got all the
sources
um you know easy to see here on each of
these which you know people can go
check you know it requires analysis uh
but uh you know
but unless unless there's a cabal
like globally across all of these
countries
fabricating numbers in the direction of
a cheap drug
that no multinational is going to profit
maximally from
in order to what save save lives like i
mean
or like it's not saving lives and then
what like there's there's there's
nothing else out there
that we have seen that is having this
kind of effect so
the tool for this or the tool that i use
at least is
okay you've got some sort of a pattern
right there's a clear pattern you see
ivermectin introduced you see
case levels and deaths absolutely oh
lindsay can i just tell my screen here
thank you you see the cases and deaths
crash
following ivermectin now
some part of you is probably thinking
well
correlation does not imply causation and
that's true but
here's the next step of that these are
not perfect experiments right in fact
they're not experiments at all
it's an observation of a pattern in
nature the pattern is rough none of
these
uh these locales are comparable with
each other they may have similarities
they will certainly have differences the
people involved are different the
coveted strains are different
everything's different it's a chaotic
system
right but what would have to be true
to generate a pattern that clear
over that many yes non-comparable
places right so that's what you need to
ask yourself is what is the size and
nature of the thing that would explain
this
that isn't ivermectin right and you know
you've just done it
it would have to be like you know
some kind of cabal to fake a pattern
to sell a generic drug to
i mean it doesn't make any sense so the
point is you yes there are things that
data
could not reflect anything that has
happened medically on the ground at all
the data could be entirely fake but what
would have to be true
panama and slovakia and the czech
republic and all of these states in
india and mexico and also there's
evidence from other countries too these
just happen to be the ones for which we
have nice clean graphs at the moment
right so at the very least if your
skepticism
is about the fact that there's no you
know there is no
uh randomized controlled trial of a
certain
size that says x y or z yeah that may
well be true but there's a whole
heck of a lot of evidence and that whole
heck of a lot of evidence could in
principle be explained by other things
but those other things are remarkable
right
so actually i wanted to addre i wanted
to address this
very thing because um the uh
the smug insistence on twitter and every
other earthly venue by people who think
that they are in the right for saying
that the evidence on ivermectin is scant
or non-existent because it doesn't meet
a certain
standard right these people are
i mean they're numbskulls at the very
least and and the reason that they're
numbskulls is this
and you know you and i know this very
very well it's great
when you have a laboratory environment
in which things are clean and you can
set up
your experimental apparatus so that
everything is
limited to the one variance between the
test and the control
that you want to observe the consequence
of that's great when you can do that
huge sample sizes are freaking awesome
right um but these things are not
necessary to do science they are not
necessary to see
patterns and to understand them and to
test them rigorously
and you know nothing proves this better
than you know the work
of field biologists because i mean we
have the most
stupidly complex noisy
uncooperative environments imaginable
i'm actually reminded um there's a lot
of places to go here of course but
um when we were in grad school we were
in what was called an integrated biology
department which is you know going
the way of the dodo like most for the
most part you have the evolution in
ecology people and
like zoology people and botany people
like whole organism people
in one department and then you have the
cellular molecular people or genetics or
development or you know whatever it is
in a different place and and broadly
speaking this isn't entirely true but
broadly speaking the cell molecular
development genetics people
are working in labs and then over here
in evolution ecology space we're working
in the field and there's of course lots
of lab work that you can do
in order to discern the deep history of
organisms and all of this but
um it's sort of you know field work
versus lab work is one of the
distinctions of the type of work that we
do
and one of the misunderstandings that
used to drive us field biologists
somewhat crazy
was that the lab biologists having
chosen of their own free will what kind
of science
they want to do when perhaps for
instance i was getting ready to go live
in a tent for five months in a rain
forest and shower in a waterfall and
watch
you know discover the sex lives of
poison frogs which i can
glamorize i can make that sound awesome
and i can also tell you a lot of stories
that explain why actually most people
wouldn't last two weeks in that
situation
they would say oh you're gonna have fun
on vacation right
and you're like okay you want to be a
field biologist go try it and see how
see if you hack it and of course this is
one of the things i also tried to do
when i was teaching animal behavior like
actually what we're trying to do here is
to see if your romanticized version of
what it is to actually go into the field
and study bats or frogs or monkeys or
parrots or whatever it is
is any match for the nature
documentaries that make it seem really
easy and fun and super comfortable
so field work is fundamentally different
and
the the lab scientists have for a long
time
imagined that what we're doing isn't
quite serious
well true it's not just the field versus
the lab though it's also
the subject matter right if you're
trying to extract a
pattern in the field in a tropical
rain forest you know you're up against
the fact that it's not a lab you know
you may have an idea that you want to
set up
a pool in uh you know a bunch of
different locations with different light
regimes to see
you know what the effect is of x y or z
and the type of frogs that show up or
who knows what you're doing right
and then you may have a tree fall take
out three of your pools one night
and the point is okay your experiment
just uh you know
through no fault of your own suddenly
got smaller but
the point is it still works
right you can still figure out what's
going on in nature in spite of the fact
that you're you know
you're wearing rubber boots right you're
carrying you know your machete you're
having to
the point is the environment that
requires these this is not a scalpel
oh no it's not yeah this so you know by
the way this is my
actual field hat i take a lot of crap
for it as if i'm
uh you know in costume or something but
these are great and this is my
brand new made for me by our friend dave
stevens machete so i have not actually
had this in the field
nor have i taken a machete into the
field recently but there were a couple
field seasons where i needed it so
yeah but you know i think the point is
machetes are not scalpels
right right but that does not mean
that you are not capable of doing
science where a machete is the
appropriate tool and a scalpel is near
use
useless right the fact is science
works because the method is so freaking
robust that it can actually
tolerate all kinds of things like not
having a randomized controlled trial but
having
a natural experiment among different
localities that have introduced the same
drug at a particular moment and you can
see
even though these curves are freaking
noisy right
you can see that the effect is the same
each time so the question is
look if you want to insist on these
other higher quality experiments less
noisy environments for the experiments
better experimental design that's great
but you're going to deny people a
treatment that obviously
works because it didn't you know the
because the experiment wasn't pristine
good god do you know who didn't have
randomized control trials
there are a few in history who have made
modest contributions modest
contributions um
you have any in mind yeah yeah i do uh
galileo
galileo pasture right galileo was
actually
darwin oh yeah um
right so darwin the the guy who uh
his commute in the field at least
sometimes involved
riding tortoises yeah so you said this
to me earlier today i was like i gotta
find this
so apparently it's in apparently the
voyage of the beagle
um but here we have it and i was like i
can't find it in here i find reference
in peer-reviewed papers that suggest
that yes that's true so that's i can't
find a quote from him saying today i
wrote a tortoise
well that's too bad but what he but what
he did do is
uh i mean to use your language from
earlier today it was like he just
flung all his finches into bags because
he wasn't being careful yeah
and then afterwards he went to this is
your word for i didn't actually make
sure that
apparently he went to captain fitzroy's
um
stuff who had taken better care in
collecting these birds from different
islands and like hey dude can i actually
use your specimens because
i think i'm seeing something i think i'm
on to something here i think i recognize
a pattern
recognizing a pattern that may actually
unravel all of this glory that is the
universe we're living in
but i can't do it with my birds because
i was messy in data collection
and so yeah he would he didn't do a
perfect job on the field biology front
but he also did
a you know one of the most important
jobs in lots of other areas yeah he
didn't have the degree
that someone might want to insist on
yeah right he uh
he rode tortoises to work he scooted off
your
tortoises to work i'm going to say he
rode tortoises to work
he wrote a 19th century ship to work
true nitrogen i mean
this was a guy was brought on to the
beagle to be
a proper companion for the captain who
was going to drive himself insane
talking to people of a lower class that
is to say
sailors for the entire voyage and so he
needed somebody of a certain
level of erudition in order to have
pleasant dinner conversation and that
guy happened to be charles darwin and
he saw south america and he saw the
galapagos and then he realized
what had been bugging him all along you
know once he was already
back home you know and he had to source
uh you know birds that had been more
carefully collected because at first he
assumed the birds from all the islands
were
interchangeable so anyway the point is
okay what did he do
well he produced by and actually you
allude to uh
this very thing in what you read earlier
he darwin created what actually there's
a strong argument this is dawkins
argument
strong argument to be made is the best
scientific theory ever and i do mean
theory because that's what it is
okay it was offered as a hypothesis but
it is now a theory
and why do i say it's the the most
important or best scientific
um hypothesis now theory ever
is because it explained more and assumed
less than any other that's the equation
how good
is your theory how much does it explain
and how much does it assume and that
ratio
explains more assumes less is a
maximally efficient fit for all of the
available data
there it is and so okay these scientists
who contributed more than any other by
at least one strongly defensible
measure was working under
weird field conditions in which
experiments were difficult if not
impossible he was observing
patterns between islands that weren't
incomparable
you know that there are no two galapagos
islands that are the same
no way yep i'm telling you wow i know
how can we know anything how can you
know
anything right they're not randomized
also this is what statistics is for but
oh wow statistics hey no that's the
point
the galapagos islands they're not
comparable nobody randomized them
this is what the scientific method is
for that's like the scientific method
all the hypotheses on the table people
like no you don't get to pretend that
one of them is off the table and then
reintroduce it
and you you know you need to have
careful experimental design and your
your design to test between hypotheses
might be observational as long as it's a
test it's still a test
and then you might you need to use
statistics to determine whether or not
what you're seeing is actually
unlikely to have happened by chance and
you know most of that
is not what darwin was doing he was
seeing pattern and
he was pretty sure that the pattern that
he was seeing in the finches and in the
tortoises
and the you know all the other things
that he was seeing that once he got back
back home like the mollusks um
meant something that was global right it
assumed less it explained tomorrow
it was maximally good fit for all of the
data right and so okay that's like the
greatest
scientific theory of all time because it
covers something really freaking
important
but here we're talking about a question
that might be among the most important
scientific questions of all time
is there a substance that's easily
available on earth that could safely
treat and prevent
covid and end this goddamn pandemic
right that's like a
similar magnitude question and we're
treating it
with these sort of idiotic rubrics in
which the only data we accept is data
that's beyond anything one could hope to
collect on a short time scale which is
insane because we do exactly the
opposite thing
with things like the emergency use
authorization where we realize
this is an emergency there are some
vaccines we can't go through the regular
process so let's speed it up
that same reduction the same instinct to
reduce the standard that i believe
is correctly applied to something like a
novel vaccine
would be correctly applied here and
i would further say that there are only
two
explanations for these scientists and
others who are parroting them who
are attempting to inflict this
incredibly high standard on ivermectin
for no obvious reason they are getting
in the way of good science
in favor of almost impossibly great
science
uh in light of the pressure the time
pressure here
the only two explanations are either
they get it and they're comfortable with
people dying because they're going to
set this really
hard standard or they're uh you know
they're
some of the dodos you were describing
earlier
which ones the ones that are now extinct
it's a play on dodo yeah
yeah well i'm i'm hoping their style of
analysis and control of the world goes
extinct but
yes i don't i don't see any evidence
that they're those dodos
uh no they they are very much with us
and they're very much obstructing this
process
yeah um that went through the bottleneck
um
also i mean not that we need it
but uh and i haven't had time to assess
it yet but zach uh
just put up this preprint that i found
just before we went to air called six
rcts control trials uh recently
published in mainstream scientific
journals that confirm major
statistically significant benefits of
ivermectin
against coven 19 as reported in several
prior
rcts there it is
again i haven't i haven't assessed the
article yet but um
there are a lot of people out there who
are trying to
to bring all of this to light and we are
some of them so
zach something i wanted to send zach but
i think i can't do it
okay um finally
you want to talk about what you have
been calling monkeying with the baseline
covet edition yeah all right monkeying
with the bass line covington we're done
doing field work
for now i'm hoping to get back oh my god
yeah i very much want to get back to the
amazon
all right so the monkeying with the
baseline thing is actually in some ways
a continuation of the same
topic and the idea is all right we
appear to have
a safe and effective treatment people
who are
looking at these massive waves of death
in places like goa
and uttar pradesh and mexico city
are using it because they're just
out of options and what do you know
it seems to work up against that
is the alternative that i think
everybody who's thought about
why we are not using the safe and
effective treatment
you know why we are not foot on the gas
on that solution
has come to the conclusion this has
something to do with an obsession
about getting everybody vaccinated an
obsession which you and i have pointed
out and i haven't heard this
said elsewhere but the fact is if your
point is herd immunity is the way we get
out of covid
then you should be thrilled even if you
think everybody who is
vaccine hesitant is an idiot you should
be thrilled for all of those idiots
to have access to ivermectin because it
works and if you put them together with
people who've had covet and are immune
people who've been vaccinated and are at
least somewhat immune and
you know that that composite just has to
get above whatever number it is
that creates herd immunity whether it's
70 80 90 we don't know but you're a lot
more likely to get there
if we do the composite thing than if you
say it's vaccines for everybody no
matter what
so i don't know what it explains their
inconsistency on this it seems to me
that
that
does point in the direction of vaccine
and business
if you really want everybody vaccinated
rather than everybody immune
through some mechanism that says there's
something unnatural about the desire to
put a needle in people's arm here well i
mean and there's just the obvious
perverse financial incentive that we
talked about with regard to
the eua not being able to be grantable
if there had been a viable treatment
right but here's the thing that occurred
to me about this and
you know granted this is still a new
thought and i'm still wrestling with its
implications they're very uncomfortable
and i
even even if it's right i think caution
on the way there is
is warranted but
if these vaccines these vaccines we have
established through i think
incontrovertible logic here these
vaccines are not
safe right whatever we can say about the
harm that they do or not or don't do the
fact that we don't know anything about
their long-term
impacts at least opens the possibility
that they do something that's bad that
we shouldn't want to happen to people
and that means they're not safe in the
same way
a gun of unknown loadedness is not safe
right so if you were going to deploy
a technology like a novel vaccine that
is in some way not safe
and it is your business right these are
business people who worry about
things like liability right if you were
going to
deploy such a thing you would have one
eye on the what if things go wrong in
some way maybe we couldn't have even
really foreseen it maybe we had no
choice because
you know the the pandemic was what it
was
right but for some reason your feeling
is well i really hope that there's
nothing we don't know because
business-wise that could be a disaster
one thing that's true is if everybody is
vaccinated
then it becomes much harder to know what
harms have actually resulted from
vaccination
and so i know you have a skepticism
about it yeah so
yeah you've said that i guess you've
said this to me before um
that requires a hundred percent like if
you really so if
what it sounds to me like you were
saying is that the
the push to get absolutely everyone
vaccinated um
could be an attempt to make sure there's
no control group
right and um the fact is that
there's not a population out there over
i don't know a thousand people where
everyone is going to get vaccinated
there's some people for whom they have
health conditions
that will preclude it there are some
people who are too young there are some
people who are just going to be hesitant
for
some stupid reasons and some smart
reasons and everything in between
so um the idea that um they
actually thought that they would get to
100 and thus eradicate any control group
seems really unlikely to me i don't
think they thought that
but i do think i thought yeah i thought
that's what i heard you arguing
well the logic goes that way you know
ideally
if you knew that you were deploying
something that might have some hazard
built in and you wanted to
hedge out the risk that that hazard
showed up in a courtroom and
resulted in a massive judgment against
you or something like that
you would ideally want 100 right but you
don't need 100
because for one thing to the extent that
there is a
huge pressure to get vaccinated
even for people for whom this is insane
right giving a vaccine to people who
already have the very same immunity
that the vaccine will give them because
they've already had covid
yep right means that whatever unknown
risks are downstream
you're exposing them to for no good
reason so
that's weird that they are not i mean
even just it is weird but it doesn't
like without being able to get the
control group to zero you still have a
group that you can compare to i don't
think so because we've seen what style
of logic gets deployed in the space
anyway right the same style of logic
that says
you certainly couldn't know that
ivermectin works if you don't have
randomized controlled trials of a
certain size
right is going to say we can guarantee
that what it's going to say downstream
is okay you've shown us a difference
between
this population that didn't have the
vaccine and that population that
did happen in terms of pericarditis
heart heart problems
heart problems strokes autoimmunity
whatever it is just stick to one just
okay so what's the but the point is yeah
but these groups aren't comparable
right for one thing you know you've got
a huge number of people
who are anti-vaxxers who didn't get the
vaccine
and that's not a random group because
for one thing those people are exposed
look i'm not arguing obviously i'm
making a garbage argument right now
right but my point maybe it's a failure
of imagination on my part to imagine
just how garbagey the argument could be
and still get accepted by a lot of
people
the amazing thing is that you are not
imagining a really really garbagey
argument even though
like four minutes ago we were talking
about a really really garbagey argument
that's being deployed in the present
with
hundreds of thousands or possibly
millions of lives on the line right so
that's the point
is still it seems a little bit epicycly
to be saying oh but they're they're
gonna make this garbage argument like
there's a billion garbage arguments that
could be made and you know i'm certain
as you are that some of them will be
made and some of them will get accepted
by way too many people but
this one seems like one among many that
is
you know patently garbagey all right and
you know maybe would be one that they
make but it
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna up my game then
all right okay let's do it
these things are um
always composites these things being if
you are going to hedge out
a legal liability
right it's not like you're gonna make
one argument
and go all in on it what you're gonna do
is you're gonna try to get as much of
that argument as you can
right you're gonna try to confuse things
as much as possible
right and then you're going to use other
stratagems and
other arguments elsewhere so you know on
the one hand
you would want really good data on harms
right
now for whatever reason the system that
collects data
on vaccine harms has certain biases in
it
right it's hard to submit things to this
system
and the limits on what is credible are
onerous right and so anyway the point is
the data itself
is compromised by a system that seems uh
fairly well designed to obscure
many incidents that are actually
probably connected
right so at the same time if you cause
everybody as many people as possible to
be
in the treatment group right and then
the control group
is increasing the bigger the pressure
you put so that it encompasses
more and more people who just say yeah
fine i'll get the vaccine
right to the extent that you do that you
create
a more rarefied and bizarre group of
holdouts
right the stronger the pressure the the
more extraordinary the conditions are
that will put you in the hole after yeah
and those people are easier to to
partition off and separate from the herd
and point to as weirdos and
especially so okay you've got hey you
just saw a really garbage
argument deployed you know at incredible
amplitude with ivor mechtin
and you on the lab leak what what did
you see
well you saw the impossibility for
people to contemplate an argument based
on the people that they thought were
saying it being
morally compromised by connection to
trump or whatever
right so yeah that's two right
i do not doubt the ubiquity of garbage
arguments no that's not my point my
point is to the extent that the group of
uh of i think um
those of us who are uh vaccine what's
the word hesitant
uh who are vaccine hesitant coveted
vaccine called
very well very well said covet vaccine
hesitant where rabies vaccinated
yellow fever vaccinated and all the rest
all the rest covered vaccine
covenant vaccine hesitant that those
people are going to be lumped in with
the
anti-vaxxers and the people who think
that there are microchips in these
vaccines and all of that
means it's going to be the same thing
where it's like you know you can almost
imagine them writing the arguments
downstream you know if there were harms
they'll write the
the article that says well okay it turns
out now that nicholas wade has
you know put the data he doesn't he
doesn't deserve our own no he doesn't
and i
i liked his article i just don't like
the idea that the world is going to get
the pivot point yeah right it was a
great article but it wasn't the first of
its kind for sure
right no and there was i i think i think
there was nothing new
on earth there maybe there was a quote
quotation from certainly the david
baltimore thing was pivotal
but it wasn't evidence it was right it
was it was again it was social evidence
right it was social evidence yeah not
scientific evidence right but anyway my
point is
we've seen that argument isn't credible
because some people who are saying it
are awful
right that we've seen that argument
already with covid and
we've seen um a really dumb argument
over whether or not there's evidence
sufficient to use ivermectin
on covid deployed and my point is those
two arguments
tell us what style of argument we're
going to face here if there is anything
to be said about
downstream stuff on the vaccines and my
point is yeah it's not that they don't
have to get
to everybody they just need to make a
lopsided situation where
the argument is hard for the opponents
they need to make all of us who aren't
in on their game the deplorables right
we all have and we've been deplorable
already on the lab league hypothesis so
this is just round two
yeah or rats can be round three in light
of men light of ivermectin
i feel like that is working for them now
but it didn't work for hillary clinton
when she first invoked that line
calling half the population deplorables
and
i just i wish i wish that the people
who like to talk about bringing everyone
together and moving forward and
finding justice and peace and freedom
and all actually meant
any of those things yeah i mean the
the disingenuousness the hypocrisy is
uh jaw-dropping yeah to be sure
to be sure all right so there's another
topic but i think i should hold it for
next time
i mean all of these things circle back
on each other so all right
well so next time which will not be
again a week from now but
we'll probably be before two weeks from
now uh
we will be talking about chapter one of
our book we encourage you to
pre-order that now at the website link
that is already in the video description
and we'll continue to be
right now we're going to take a
15-minute break and for those of you
watching we'll be back with that live q
a answering questions you have posed
during this hour and during the next
hour again please
uh please consider joining either or
both of us at our patreons at mine you
get access to a
two-hour private q a that we do on the
last sunday of the month and at brett's
uh you get access to a couple of smaller
conversations
one of which is happening tomorrow one
of which happened today was
excellent wonderful and you can access
the discord server on both of those as
well
we have um our excellent moderator has
an email at darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com where you can send not
questions for us to answer in the q a
but logistical questions um how to send
us things how to ask questions
these this sort of thing um our clips
channel
which as we mentioned has begun to draw
the attention
of the of the google monsters uh
is going strong hopefully still will
continue to
it is generating a lot of attention and
that's mostly what we want we want eyes
on the content that reveals reality
and an ability to discern what is true
so
please consider not just for this
channel but also the dark harps
dark corpse the darkhorse clips
channel uh darkhorse podcast clips i
think is what it's called
um subscribe to the channel like the
videos
and share them as widely as you can
across
across platforms uh so that uh if
if if one of the platforms is feeling
sensorious today perhaps another one
won't be
anything else to say i don't think so
all right then um be
good to the ones with whom you live and
eat good food and by all means get
outside
get outside achieve greatness and if you
see somebody monkeying with the baseline
grab them by the lapels and shake them
vigorously
and get outside and get
you